Quiz two is this
week on Friday from,
I hope that's
correct, whatever's
on the webpage is correct,
but I think it's lecture 9
through recitation number 15.
So, in particular,
the log structure
file system paper
is not on the exam.
Some of you may have
been told otherwise.
What we're going to
do today is continue
our discussion of atomicity.
Which, as you'll recall,
is two properties
that have to hold in order
for atomicity to hold.
And the first property
that we talked about
was recoverability.
And the other
property, which is what
we're going to spend most of
our time on today, is isolation.
So, before we get
into isolation,
I just want to wrap up the
discussion of recoverability
because we left it a little
bit of three-quarters
and didn't quite finish it.
So the story here
was what we did
first was talked
about how to achieve
a recoverable sector
using two copies
of the data and the chooser
sector to choose between them.
We talked about one way of
achieving recoverability
using version histories.
And we did complete
that discussion.
And then we started talking
about a more efficient way
of achieving recoverability
in situations where
you cared a lot about
performance using logging.
And the main in logging
is this protocol
for when you decide to write
the log called the write ahead
logging (WAL) protocol.
And the idea is very simple.
Always write to the log
before you update cell store.
And that's the main discipline
that if you always follow then
you'll get things right.
But one of the
consequences of logging,
you get two things
from having this log.
The first is when
an action aborts.
Independent of
failure, when you're
running an atomic
action and the program
calls abort or the system
aborts that action,
what the log allows you to do
is go back through the log,
scan the log backwards,
look at all of the steps
that that action took.
And that action
didn't quite commit
so you have to back
those changes out,
and the log helps
you unroll backward.
So primarily what you need
with a logging scheme,
in or to do aborts, is
the ability to undo.
Which means that what you need
in the log, whenever you update
a cell store to
something else, you need
to keep track of the old value.
And this is what we called
in the log as an undo step.
But now failures also happen
in addition to aborts,
and we need a little bit
more mechanism in addition
to just the ability to undo.
And to understand why, let's
take a specific example
where you have an application
and it is writing data
to a database that is on disk.
And what we said
was there was a log
and the log is stored
on disk as well.
And let's assume that
the log is actually
stored on a different disk.
Now, the write ahead
log protocol basically
says that whenever
you update, so you
have an action which
has things like
reads and writes of cell store.
And whenever there's a
write to a cell store,
the write ahead log protocol
says write to the log
before you write to the
database or to the cell store.
So two things can happen.
The first thing,
the simplest model
here is that all
writes are synchronous.
What this means
is that if you see
a write statement
in an atomic action,
the first thing you have to
do is to write to the log.
And then that returns.
And then you write
to the database.
And then you run
the next action,
the next step of the action.
So clearly by the
time in this action,
if you ever get to
the commit point
and you're about to
exit your commit,
it means that all of
the data has already
been written to the database.
Because, by assumption, we
assume that all of the writes
are synchronous and you write
to the database and only
then do you go to the next step.
And, assuming there's only
one thread of execution,
then in this simple model, you
always write to the database,
you first write to
the log and then you
write to this self-store
in the database.
But by construction, when
you get to the commit point,
you know for sure
that all of the data
has been written
to the database.
So if a failure happens now
and you didn't get to commit
and the system failed
before the commit ran
any time in the
middle of this action,
the only thing you
really need to do
is to roll back all of the
changes made by actions that
didn't get to
commit, which means
that in this model that
I've described so far,
the only thing you need to do
is to undo actions that respond
to actions that didn't commit.
Any action that
committed by construction
must have written
all of its data
and installed that
data into cell store.
Because if an action gets
to the statement to run
commit and then finishes
commit, when it got to commit,
you know that because
of all the writes
being synchronous
to the cell store,
you know that that
write got written.
And, by the write
protocol's definition,
you know the log got
written before that.
So you don't actually
have to do anything.
Even though the log contains the
results of these actions that
committed, you don't
have to do anything
for the committed actions.
So, in fact, this undo
log is enough to handle
the simple database as well
where all of the writes
are being done synchronously
in this application.
But there are a few
things that can happen.
One of the reasons we
threw out version histories
or discarded the idea to go
to this logging oriented model
is for higher performance.
And one of the ways we got
higher performance is we
didn't have to do these
link list reversals in order
to read and write items.
But it's also going
to be tempting,
and you've seen
this before, to not
want to do synchronous writes
to cell store on a database
in order to get
high performance.
You might have
asynchronous writes
happening to the database
and you don't know
when those writes complete.
And what could happen,
as a result of that,
is you'd issue some
writes to the database
and then you go ahead and
you commit the action.
But what could
happen is the data
that was supposed to be
written to this database
as store may not actually have
gotten written because there's
some kind of a cache in
memory that actually returned
to you from the write, but the
write actually never made it
to the database.
So this system, for
higher performance,
if you stick the cache in
here, what could happen
is that you might
reach the commit point
and finish commit but not be
guaranteed that the cell store
data actually got
written to the database.
And if you fail
now after commit,
you have to go through the
log and redo the actions
for all of those actions
that committed because some
of those actions may not
have made it into the cell
storage in the database.
So what this means
is that in general,
when you put a cash here,
any memory cash here
or if you have any situation
where the writes are
asynchronously being
done to cell store,
you need both an undo log
in order to handle aborts
and to handle the
simple case and you
need the ability to redo the
results of certain actions
from the log.
And both of these are
done, so the system fails
and then, when you
recover, before you
allow other actions that might
be ready to go to take over,
the system has to recover
running the recovery process.
And the recovery
happens from the log.
And the way that recovery works
is, and we went through this
the last time, you
scan the log backwards
from the most recent
entry in the log.
And, while scanning the log
backwards, you make two lists.
You make a list of winners
and a list of losers.
And the winners are all
of those actions that
either committed or aborted.
And there's one important
point in the abort step, which
is that when the
system calls abort
or when the application calls
abort and abort returns, what
the system does is
goes through the log
and looks at all the
changes made by that action
and undoes all of them.
And then it writes the record,
called the abort record,
onto the log.
So when you recovery and
you see an abort record,
you already know
that those changes
made by an aborted
action have been undone.
When you compose
a list of winners
that are committed actions
and aborted actions,
the only things you
really need to redo
are the steps corresponding
to the committed actions.
You don't have to undo
the steps corresponding
to the aborted actions because
they already got undone.
Because only after they
got undone that the abort
entry was written to the log.
In addition to these
committed and aborted actions
that are winners, there
are all other actions
that were pending or active
at the time of the cache,
and those are losers.
And so what you have
to do to the losers
is to undo the actions
done by losers.
So the actual recovery step runs
after composing these winners
and losers and it corresponds
to redoing the committed winners
and undoing the losers.
And independent of
crashes, independent
of failures, when you just
have actions that might abort,
the only thing you
really need is undo.
You don't need to redo anything.
If you don't ever have any
failures but just actions
aborting, the only thing
you need to do with the log
is to undo the results
of uncommitted actions
before abort returns.
Now, this procedure is OK.
Failures happen
rarely and you're
willing to take a
substantial amount of time
to recover from a failure then
the log might be quite long.
If a system fails once a week,
your log might be quite long.
And if you're willing
to take the time
to scan through the log entirely
and build up these winners
and losers list
then this is fine,
this approach works just fine.
But people are often interested
in optimizing the time it
takes to recover from a crash.
And a common optimization that's
done is called a checkpoint.
And I believe you've
seen this in System R.
And, if you haven't
seen it, you'll
probably see it in
tomorrow's recitation.
And the main idea
in the checkpoint
is it's an optimization
that allows this recovery
process not to have to scan the
log all the way back to time
zero.
That the system periodically,
while it's normally operating,
takes this checkpoint,
which is to write
a special record into the log.
And that record basically
says at this point in time
here are all of the
actions that have committed
and whose results
have already been
installed into the cell store.
In other words, they've
committed and already
been installed so
when you recover
you don't have to go and scan
the log all the way back.
You just have to go
back enough so you
find all of the actions
whose results haven't yet
been installed completely
which have been committed.
And the checkpoint also contains
a list of all the actions
that are currently active.
So once you write a
checkpoint record to the log,
during recovery you don't have
to go all the way back in time.
There are a few
other optimizations
that you can do with
checkpoints that are not
that interesting
to get into here,
but the primary
optimization that's
done to speed up
the recovery process
is to use this
checkpoint record.
And most database systems,
the checkpoint record
is pretty small.
It's not like you're check
pointing the entire state
of the database.
The main thing
you're doing is it's
a pretty small amount of
state that you're using
to just speed up recovery.
So you shouldn't be thinking
that the checkpoint is
something where you
take the entire database
and copy it over.
That's not what goes on.
It's a pretty lightweight,
small amount of state
rather than the size of all
of the data in the system.
So that's the story
behind recoverability.
And we're actually going to come
back to a piece of the story
after we talk about isolation
now because it will turn out
that the mechanisms
for isolation
and the mechanisms
for recoverability
using logs interact
in certain ways,
so we have to come back
to this either later today
or on Wednesday.
So now we're going to start
talking about isolation.
If you remember, the
idea behind isolation
is when you have
a set of actions
that run concurrently,
what you would like
is an equivalent ordering
of the steps of the actions
running concurrently
such that the results are
equivalent to some serial
ordering of the actions.
The simple way of describing
isolation is do it all before
or do it all after.
If you have actions,
let's say T1, T2 and so
on running at the same time.
And these actions might operate
on some data that is in common,
they might act on data
that's not at all uncommon,
what you would like is an
equivalent of the state
of the system after running
these concurrent actions should
be equivalent to some serial
ordering of the actions.
And it will turn out that
what's tricky about isolation
is that if you want
isolation and you
don't care about performance
it's very, very easy to do.
So it's very easy
to get isolation
if you don't care
about performance.
It's very easy to
run fast if you
don't care about correctness.
So, you know, fast and
correct is the hard problem.
Fast and not correct is
trivial and correct and slow
is also trivial.
I mean correct and
slow is very easy
because you could take all
of these concurrent actions
and just run them
one after the other
so you don't actually
take advantage
of any potential concurrency
that might be possible.
So suddenly slow and
correct is very easy to do.
And we'll actually start
out with slow and correct
and then optimize
a simple scheme.
There has also been
a huge amount of work
that's been done on fast
and correct schemes.
And, in the end, they all boil
down to this one basic idea
that we'll talk about toward
the end of lecture today.
So let's take an example.
Let's say you have two actions.
I'm going to call them with
Ts because very often these
are intended to be
transactions which
are consistency and
durability in addition
to isolation and recoverability.
So I'm just going to use the
word T to represent an action.
Let's say you have
an action that
does read of some variable x and
it does write of a variable y
and you have transaction
T2 that does write x
and it does write y.
So we're going to take a few
examples like this in order
to understand what it means
for actions to run such
that they're steps equivalent
to some serial order.
So we're going to spend some
time really understanding that.
And then, once we
understand what we want,
it will turn out to be
relatively easy to come up
with schemes to achieve it.
Let's say that what
happens here is
that the system gets presented
with these concurrent actions.
And let's assume each of
these is an atomic step.
So there are four steps that
can be interleaving in arbitrary
ways, in any number of ways.
Let's say that what happens
is you run that first
and then you run that second
and then you run this third
and then you run this fourth.
So what you get
is that I'm going
to introduce a little
bit of a notation here.
I'm going to write these
steps as r1(x), w2(x), w1(y)
and w2(y).
What the r represents
is a read, w
represents a write, what
the subscripts represent
is the identifier of the
action doing the read or write.
And what's in parenthesis is the
variable that's being written.
So this says that action one
does a read of x, action two
does a write of x, action
one does a write of y
and action two
does a write of y.
Now, if you look at
these different actions,
there are a few steps that
conflict with each other
and a few that don't.
If you look at the read
of x and the write of y,
they're independent
of everything else.
If you just have read x
here and write y here,
they don't conflict
with each other
because those can
happen in any order
and the results are
exactly the same.
Similarly, the write
y and the write x
don't conflict with each other.
The only things that really
conflict with each other
are the read x and the
write x in this example
because the results depend
on which goes first.
Write y conflicts
with this write y,
and those are basically
the two things
that conflict with each
other in this example.
Generally, if you
have two actions
conflict with one another,
if they both contain
a read and a write of the
same variable or a write
and a write of
the same variable.
So there are basically
three things that conflict.
If you have some variable, call
it z, if you have a read of z
and a write of z in one
action or the other,
if you have write of z and read
of z or if you have write of z
and write of z and those
conflict with one another.
Now a read and a
read don't conflict.
Because it doesn't matter
what order they run in,
they are going to give
you the same answer.
If you look at this ordering
of r1(x), w2(x), w1(y)
and w2(y), the
things that conflict
are these two and these two.
Now, if you look
at the two things
that conflict and you draw
arrows from which one happens
before the other,
what you'll find
is that for this x conflict one
runs before two and for this y
conflict one runs before two.
So the arrows, if I were
to draw them in time order,
would point this way.
And this ordering is
basically the same
as the same ordering
you would get,
even though the steps
run in different order,
it's exactly the same as if you
ran T1 completely before T2.
Because running T1
completely before T2 says
the ordering is r1(x),
w1(y), w2(x) and w2(y).
But the results are
exactly the same,
this different
interleaving, which
does one, two, three, four.
So what this says is that
this trace that you get,
we're going to use the
word trace for this,
you present this concurrent
actions each of which
has one or more steps
and the system runs them.
And then the order in
which the individual steps
run produces a trace.
And then the question
is whether that trace
is what is called serializable.
A trace is serializable
if the trace's results
are identical to running the
actions in some serial order
one after the other.
And so what we're going
to be trying to do
is, what we're
going to do today is
to come up with schemes which
take these different steps
corresponding to the action that
produces an order that turns
out to be a serializable order.
And the challenge is to do
it in a way that allows you
to get reasonable performance.
To give you an example of a
nonserializable order, if we
had the following trace,
r1(x) followed by w2(x)
followed by w2(y)
followed by w1(y).
What happens here is
that these two guys
conflict so you've got an arrow
from one to two going this way.
And, similarly, these two guys
conflict but the arrow in time
goes from two to
one, which means
that if you drew the
arrow one to two this way,
you would have an arrow
going the opposite direction.
So this doesn't correspond
to any serial order
because, as far as this
conflict is concerned,
this trace says that action one
should run before action two.
And, as far as this
conflict is concerned,
it says that action two
should run before action one.
Which means you're in trouble
because there is really
no serial ordering here.
This trace does not correspond
to either T1 before T2 or T2
before T1 which
means this trace,
if you have a scheme that
runs your actions, the steps
of your action that
produces the stress it
means that that scheme
does not provide isolation.
Notice that we don't
actually care whether T1 runs
before T2 or T2 runs before T1.
We're not worried about that.
We're just worried
about producing
some serial equivalent order.
So that's the definition of
the property that we want,
serializability.
And what it says is a trace
whose conflict arrows,
these are these
conflict arrows, are
equivalent to some
serial ordering
of the steps of the action.
What we want is a
trace conflict that
should be in the same order
as some serial schedule
or some serial order
of the actions.
So what we're going to
do is in three parts.
The first part is we're going
to look at one of these traces.
And given a trace,
the first problem
is to figure out whether
that trace corresponds
to some serial order.
And then we're going to derive
a property that guarantees
that if a sudden
property holds we
would be assured that a
trace is in serial order.
And then the second
part is we are
going to come up with
various schemes for achieving
serializability.
And the third part is in order
to prove that those schemes are
correct, what we
are going to do is
to prove that this property,
that all serial orderings
should satisfy holes for the
protocol or for the algorithm
that we design.
That is the plan for
the rest of today.
This property for
serializability
is going to use data structure
or a construction called
an action graph.
And it turns out what
we are going to do,
given one of these traces,
is produce a graph out
of those traces called
the action graph.
And then we are going to look to
see whether a certain property
holds for that action graph.
Let me show you what this
action graph is by example.
The graph itself consists
of nodes and edges
It's a directed graph.
And the nodes are not
these r1s and w2s.
What the nodes are, are
the actions themselves.
So, if you have four
actions running,
you have four
nodes on the graph.
And then there are edges between
these nodes on the graph.
Let's do it by an example.
Let's say you have
first action T1 which
has read of x and write of y.
And just so we are sure
that it is action one,
I'm going to draw one
underneath as a subscript
because they're just reads.
Action two has a write
of x and a write of y.
Action three has a read of y and
a write of another variable z.
And action four has a read of x.
First of all, given these
actions, which of the actions
conflict with each other?
Let's first write for T1.
Does T2 conflict with T1?
Yes it does because
the read x, I
mean that's the same
as that example,
so suddenly T2
conflicts with T1.
What about T3?
Does T3 conflict with T1?
What that means is
the interleaving
of the individual steps matter
as far as the final answer is
concerned.
Yes, it does because
the write of y
and the read of y conflict,
so you've got T1 and T3
that you have to worry about.
Does T1 conflict with T4?
No it doesn't.
The read and the
read do not conflict.
Does T2 conflict with T3?
Yes, it does because
it has got the y.
Does T2 conflict with T4?
It does.
And does T3 conflict with T4?
It does not.
There's nothing that's shared.
Out of the six possible,
or whatever, four,
choose two possible
conflicts, for conflicts
you've got four of them that
you've got to worry about.
Now we're going to
draw this graph that
has T1, T2, T3 and
T4, and we're going
to call this the action graph.
And what it's going to do is
to draw arrows between actions
that conflict with one another.
But of course the
answer, the arrows
depend on the order in which
these individual steps get
scheduled by the system
running these actions.
We need an actual
example for that.
Let's say that what
happens is you present
these concurrent actions.
And what happens is this guy
runs first and then two, three,
four, five, six and seven.
That's the order
in which the system
runs the individual
steps of this action.
Now we're going to draw
these arrows between actions.
If two actions share a
conflicting operation
and in the first action
the conflicting operation
occurs before the
second action then
you're going to draw an
arrow from the first action
to the second action.
So more generally there's
an arrow from PI to PJ.
If I and J have a
conflicting operation
that individual step is
run by the system for I
first before J.
If you look here
at T1 to T2 there's
an arrow between T1 and T2.
Because it ran r1(x)
before it run w2(x).
If you look at T1 and T3,
this is a little subtle
because if ran read of
x before it ran r3(y),
but that doesn't matter because
read of x there and read of y
there don't conflict.
But then it ran
w1(y) after it ran
read 3y which means
that the conflict is
equivalent to running that step
of T3 before the step of T1.
So you actually have an arrow
going back from T3 to T1.
Now what about T2 and T3?
T2 and T3, the same story,
w2(x) and r3(y) don't conflict.
But r3(y) before w2(y),
that's the conflict,
so you have an arrow
going this way.
So we've got three of them,
you need a fourth one,
and that is between T2 and T4.
Between T2 and T4,
w2(x) runs before r4(x)
which means you have an
arrow going this way.
If you actually look
at this picture,
and we'll come up with a
method to systematically argue
this point, but if you
look at that schedule,
as shown here, where
the system runs
the individual
steps in that order,
this is actually
equivalent to T3
running and then
T1 running and then
T2 running and then T4 running.
The order of interleaving
these different steps
in the way shown in that
picture, one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven is actually
equivalent to the same result,
it's the same
result that you get
if you run T3 completely and
then T1 and then T2 and then
T4.
In fact, if you
think about it, it's
also equivalent to
the same ordering
that you get if you run
T3 and then you run T1
and then you run T4
and then you run T2.
That just says that for
the exact same scheduling
of individual steps in
the concurrent actions
you might find multiple
equivalent serial
orders that all give
you the same answer.
Is that clear? Yup.
Student 1: How can you write
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
Student 2: Yes, how can you write
the equivalent of [UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
Students discussing: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
Student 1: T1 and T2
need to switch.
Students discussing: No, you can't.
Students discussing: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
Instructor: Everyone see the
order or is there more?
Student 2: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
Student 1: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
Instructor: No, 3 to 1 to 4
doesn't work.
So I guess there
is just one.
It's all right. I could have
sworn with two edges
missing, could be more.
But — okay.
Student: Is the [UNINTELLIGIBLE] arrow?
Instructor: Is the arrow from 2 to 4?
Student: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
The arrow from two
to four is correct. Right?
Write effects runs
before read effects.
So I think this is correct.
Is there a problem?
Okay.
So, in this example, it
isn't multiple serial orders.
But in general it
appears that there
are multiple serial
orders possible.
Okay.
So what does this action graph
got to do with anything?
It turns out, and
we'll prove this,
that if the action graph--
--for any ordering of
steps within an action,
if the action graph
does not have a cycle--
--then the corresponding trace
from which the action graph
was derived is serializable.
What that means is that
what you have to do
is, given a certain
ordering of steps,
you construct this
action graph, you
look to see if it
has any cycles.
And, if it doesn't
have any cycles,
then you know that the order is
equivalent to some serial order
of the steps of the
individual actions.
And it actually turns out the
result is a bit more powerful.
The converse is also
true that if you
have a serializable trace then
the corresponding action graph
has no cycles.
Now, to turn out, the more
interesting result for us
is going to be the
following direction
where if the graph is acyclic
then the trace is serializable.
Because what we're
going to end up
doing is inventing one or
two protocols for achieving
isolation, for achieving
serializability.
And we're going to prove
that those protocols are
correct by proving that the
corresponding action graph, all
of the possible action graphs
produced by those protocols
all have no cycles.
So this direction is the
direction that's actually
more important for
us, but the opposite
is also true and not
that hard to prove.
So what is the
intuition behind why,
if you have an action
graph that's serializable,
sorry, that doesn't have cycles
the trace is serializable?
Well, notice one
thing about this
which is to draw a
little bit of intuition.
Suppose, in fact,
what happened here
was we didn't execute
the actions, the steps
in that order, but what we did
was to run this at step five
and that at step six.
What would happen with
the resulting action graph
is that you would actually
have an arch from T2 to T1
going the other way as well.
Because what this says
is between T1 and T2
there is one
conflicting operation
that goes this way where
action one runs before two.
And these two guys conflict
where the step in two
runs before the step in
one and those two steps
conflict with one another.
And this is actually
the cycle here
that causes the whole scheme
to be not serializable anymore.
That's a little bit of intuition
as to why this acyclic property
is important.
But to really prove
this notice that if you
have a directed acyclic
graph you could do something
called a topological
sort on the graph.
How many people know what
a topological sort is?
OK.
For those who don't,
the idea is very simple.
In any directed
acyclic graph there
is going to be at
least one node that
has no arrows coming into it.
All of the arrows going out
are only going out of the node.
And you can actually prove that
by arguing the contradiction.
If it turns out that every
node has an arch coming in
and an arch going out
then by traversing
that chain of pointers
you'll end up with a cycle.
So it's pretty easy to see that
in any directed acyclic graph
you're going to
have some node that
has no arrows coming into it
and only arrows going out of it.
So find that action, in
this picture it is T3,
and take that action
and put it in first.
That's the first
action that you run.
Because it has no
arrows coming into it
and only arrows going
out, what that means
is that no other action in a
serial order runs before it.
Or at least there's no
reason for any action
to run before it
because there are
no arrows from any other
action coming into this action.
So you put that in first.
Now, remove that node
from the entire graph.
The resulting graph
is acyclic, right?
You cannot manufacture a cycle
by removing a node so you
recursively apply the same idea,
find some other node which has
no other things coming into
it and only things going out
of it.
And if there are ties
just pick one at random.
And, therefore,
construct an order.
And all such orders
that you construct
are topological sort orders.
This topological sort
order, by construction,
is a serial order
of the actions.
And this topological sort,
if you now draw the arrows
in the topological
sort, they're going
to be the same arrows as in
the original directed graph,
it's exactly the same
graph, and now you have
an equivalent serial order.
That's the reason why the cyclic
property is actually important
as far as serializability
is concerned.
Now we can look at
schemes that actually
guaranty serializability.
And the schemes we're going to
discuss all are in this system
where you have cell
storage and where
you have logs for recovery.
The logs are not going to
matter, for the most part.
You can also do isolation
in version histories,
and one of the sections
of the notes deals
with that at length.
I personally think it's
not that important,
but that doesn't mean
it's not on the quiz.
I think you get a little
bit more intuition
reading that in addition
to this discussion.
And a bulk of this discussion
is actually not in the notes.
It's just another way of
looking at the problem.
The mechanism we're
going to build on
is, in fact, described
in the notes as well.
It's a mechanism you've seen
before, and it is called locks.
As you recall, if you have
variable x or any chunk of data
you can protect it using two
calls, acquire and release.
So you could do things
like acquire lock
of x and release lock of x.
And the lock protocol
is that only one person
can acquire a lock at a time.
And all of the people wanting
all other actions wishing
to acquire the same lock will
wait until the lock is released
and then they fight
to acquire it.
And ultimately at
the lowest level
the lock has to be implemented
with some low level
atomic instruction.
For example, something like a
test and set lock instruction.
It's the same story as before.
Now, there are a few things
to worry about with locks.
The first one is the
granularity of the lock.
You could be very,
very conservative
and decide that the
granularity of the lock
is your entire system.
So all of the data
on the system gets
protected with one lock, which
means that you're running
this very slow scheme because
what you're guaranteeing
is, in fact,
isolation but you're
running essentially
one action at a time
and you have no
concurrency at all.
The other extreme, you could
be very, very aggressive
and every individual
cell stored item
is protected with the lock.
And now you're trying to max
out the degree of concurrency,
which means that although
things could be fast
you have to be a lot more
careful if you want things
to be correct.
And correct here
means that you have
an order that is equivalent
to some serial order.
Why does the locking
protocol actually matter?
Well, let's go back to these two
action examples of r1(x) w2(x)
and w1(y) and w2(y).
And let's just throw in
an acquire lock of x here
and an acquire lock of y here
and a release lock of x here
and in between here
you have the read
and here you do the
release of the lock of y
and similarly you do
an acquire lx here
and you do an acquire ly here.
And then you release the
locks at the end here.
So acquire lock x, read x,
release lock x, acquire lock y,
write y, release lock
y, and acquire right,
acquire right, release, release.
And, on the face of
it, this kind of thing
is actually reasonable for the
old style synchronization, some
of the old style
synchronization things
that we wanted because we didn't
actual care about atomicity
of full actions.
If you look at what happens
with this kind of locking,
as shown here, you might
be a little bit in trouble
because it could be that
these three steps happen first
and then this whole set of
steps up to here happen second,
actually, up to the end.
And then this chunk
happens third.
Now you're in
trouble because read
x happens before write
x and the write y
happens before this write y.
And now you have not
achieved isolation
because, if you draw
the conflict graph,
you'll get an
arrow from T1 to T2
and an arrow coming
back from T2 to T1
and you have a cycle, which
means that just throwing
in the right
acquires and releases
isn't going to be sufficient
to achieve isolation.
So we're going to need a much
better set of skills, a better
scheme than just this
throw in the right
acquires and releases.
The first scheme we're going
to see is a simple scheme.
It's called simple locking.
The idea in simple locking
is that every action
knows beforehand all
of the data items
that it wants to
read or write, and it
acquires all of the locks
before it does anything.
Before doing any reads or writes
it acquires all of the locks.
The idea would be here you
would acquire the lock of x
and acquire the lock of y,
and then you run the steps.
Similarly, the other
action does the same thing.
And by construction,
if you have actions
that conflict with one
another and one of the actions
reaches the point where
all of the locks it needs
have been acquired
then by construction
no other conflicting action
could be in the same state.
Because if you have another
action that conflicts then
it means that there's at least
one data item common to them
which means that
only one of them
could have reached this
point because they're both
trying to acquire.
This protocol where every
action acquires all of the locks
before running any step of the
action will guaranty isolation.
And the isolation order,
the equivalent serial order
that it guarantees is
the same as the order
in which the different actions
reach this point where they
have acquired all of the locks.
And that point is also
called the lock point.
The lock point of
an action is defined
as the point where all of the
locks that it needs or it wants
to acquire have been acquired.
And, because in this
discipline where no action does
any operation until all
of the locks it needs
have been acquired,
you're guaranteed
that this serial order
of every action following
this protocol,
independent of knowledge
of any other actions,
everybody just blindly follows
this protocol, the
serial order is the same
as if the actions
had run in the order
of acquiring the lock points,
whatever that order might be.
This is called simple locking,
and it does provide isolation.
But the problem
with simple locking
where you acquire all of the
locks before running anything
is two-fold.
The first problem is
that this dictates
that all of the actions know the
different items that they want
to read or write beforehand.
Which means that if you're
deep inside some action
and there are all sorts
of conditional statements
you kind of have
to know beforehand
all of the data items you
might be reading and writing.
And that could be pretty tricky.
In practice, if you want
to adopt simple locking,
you might have to
be very conservative
and sort of try to
lock everything or lock
a large amount of data
which reduces performance.
Second, it actually doesn't
give you enough opportunity
to get high performance,
even when you do know all
of the data items beforehand.
For example, one
thing you could do
is acquire the lock
of x and then read x.
And while you're off trying
to read x then you might
acquire a lock of y and read y.
And so, depending on how you
have structured your system
scheme where you
do some work, maybe
some computation as
well in between the lock
acquisition steps might
give you higher performance.
So the question is can we be
a little bit more aggressive
than the simple
locking scheme in order
to get isolation as well as a
little bit higher performance?
And the answer is that
there is such a scheme
and it's called
two-phase locking.
And although a lot
of work has happened
for maybe a couple of decades
on very high performance
locking schemes, it turns out
in the end they all, or at least
for a large class
of schemes that
use this kind of locking they
all boil down to some variable
of two-phase locking.
And the idea is very simple.
The two-phase locking
idea says there
should be no release before
all the acquires are done.
So do not release any lock
until all of the locks
that you need have been applied.
That's what happens here.
This schemes violates two-phase
locking because you actually
release lock x before
you acquire lock y,
and that violated
two-phase locking.
And this idea that you
don't release before all the
acquires, there is a little
bit of a subtlety that
happens because you
want recoverability
which is that the action
could at any stage abort.
And, in order to
abort an action,
you need to go back
and undo that variable,
the value to a previous value.
Which means that
in order to abort
you need to hold onto the lock.
You better make sure that
an action in order to abort
has the locks for
all of the data items
whose values it wishes to
change to the original value.
Which means that in practice,
at least for all the items
that you're writing,
the locks that you hold
should not be released
until the commit point,
until the place where
the action calls commit.
So no release
before all acquires
is basically equivalent to--
There should be no
acquire statement
after any release statement.
The moment you see a release
statement and then an
acquire after that
of anything, then
you know that this
violates two-phase locking.
It turns out that two-phase
locking is correct
that it provides isolation.
And to see why let's
look at a picture.
We're going to go back
to this action graph idea
and look at a picture of what
happens with two-phase locking.
What we're going to
prove is that if you
use two-phase locking and
you construct an action
graph of what you get from
running a sequence of steps
that action graph has no cycles.
And we know that if you have
no cycles in the action graph
you're guaranteed
that it is equivalent
to some serial order.
We will argue this
by contradiction.
Let's say you have T1 and T2 all
the way through some action Tk
and you have a cycle going back
from Tk to T1 in the action
graph.
Now, if there is an
arrow from T1 to T2,
it means that there
is some data item
x1 in common between T1 and T2.
And you know that T2 ran after
T1 which means that in T1 there
was a release done of l1
after which in the system
there was an acquire done of l1.
Likewise, between T2 and T3,
there is some data item x2 such
that a release was
done of l2 by T2.
And after that an acquire
was done of l2 by T3.
And the release has to have been
done after the acquire of l1
because we're following
two-phase locking.
If you continue that down
up to here out for Tk,
Tk did an acquire somewhere
later in time of lk minus one.
And then it did a release of
some data item, a lock of lk
where lk is actually
some data item that
is shared between Tk and T1,
so there is actually some data
item xk whose lock is lk.
And you know that Tk
did a release of lk
before T1 did an acquire of lk.
But the T1's acquire
of lk must have
happened after
the release for lk
so it must have happened
at some point here.
T1 must have done an acquire of
lk at some point at the bottom
here.
Just going out in
time, by two-phase
locking you get release
of l1, then the other guy
doesn't acquire of
l1, release of l2,
acquire of l2 all the way out,
then release of lk, and then
after that in time
an acquire of lk.
So that must have
happened later on in time,
but now this picture
here violates two-phase
locking because T1,
for this cycle to hold,
has to have done an acquire
of lk after release of l1.
But that violates two-phase
locking because you're not
allowed to acquire
anything after you've
released something.
So two-phase locking,
therefore, cannot have a cycle
in the action graph.
And, from the previous
story, it means
that it's equivalent to
some serial order that
corresponds to the
topological sort
of the directed acyclic graph.
I'm going to stop here.
We will continue with
this stuff and then
talk about other aspects
of transactions next time.
And if there are any questions
either send me an email
or ask me the next time.